welcome back okay we're talking about
dynamical systems and in this lecture I
wanted to show you how easy it is to
simulate chaotic dynamical systems like
the Lorentz system in MATLAB okay so
what we're gonna do to start off with
I'm just going to write down remind you
that we're talking about differential
equations DDT of some state vector x
equals some function of X maybe it
depends on time T and maybe there's some
vector of parameters in beta okay so
we're going to be dealing with these
differential equations X dot equals f of
X comma T comma beta and right now what
we're gonna do is we're gonna talk about
the Lorentz system so the Lorentz system
this is one of the earliest models for
for chaos by Lorentz I think this was
1963 and this is a simple
three-dimensional model that gets a lot
of the features of chaotic turbulent
atmospheric convection and it's really
simple it's given by three differential
equations X dot y dot and Z dot so X dot
y dot Z dot equals some parameter Sigma
times y minus X some parameter X times
Rho minus Z minus y and then the third
equation is X Y minus beta Z okay so a
really simple differential equation
notice that it has these three
parameters Sigma Rho and beta and so I'm
gonna put those all onto this big bold
vector beta so bold beta is going to be
a vector of Sigma Rho and this little
beta here okay so my three parameters of
Lorentz are going to go into this vector
of parameters maybe I'll make this a
column vector by transposing it and I'm
going to make my nice state vector so
this x y&z are going to go into a state
vector bold x equals XY
and Z transpose so it's a column vector
okay so I have this differential
equation so basically X is a three
dimensional state vector F is three
components of a vector field and there
are three parameters in beta and this
will give me some dynamics that will
kind of oscillate around one lobe and
then it'll jump to another lobe and then
oscillate back and kind of do this
classical Lorentz dynamics that's what a
trajectory is going to do okay so we're
going to code this up in MATLAB and this
should be pretty simple okay so to code
up in MATLAB we're going to start with
just a blank script called sim Lorentz
dot M and here what we're going to do is
we're going to use the ode45 command in
MATLAB that's kind of an OD e integrator
and we're going to integrate our Lorentz
vector field so maybe the first thing I
should do is actually make my right hand
side function this f of X function let's
do that so let's make a function called
function DX equals Lorentz and Lorentz
is going to take in an X at E and some
parameters beta and in MATLAB I it
always goes T comma X so I'm going to do
that too so we're gonna start with time
then X then beta okay and this is going
to have three output so DX there's going
to be the first component of DX the
second component of DX and the third
component so we're going to say DX
equals this vector of output so it's
going to have one two three components
the first I'm going to give myself a
little cheat sheet here just so that I
remember X 1 equals x x 2 equals y X 3
equals E and beta 1 equals Sigma beta 2
equals Rho and beta 3 equals
betta okay so I'm just giving myself
this cheat sheet I'm going to delete
this in a little bit but I want to
remember what all my variables are
called
okay and what do we have for the first
DX we have X dot equals Sigma that's
beta 1 x and this is capital Beta Sigma
times y minus X now y is x 2 and x is x
1 so this is the second component of my
state vector is y the first component is
X so this is Sigma Y minus X I know this
is a little compute confusing because
I'm using X to be my vector of states
and to be the first state and I'm using
beta to me let be my vector of state of
coefficients and also it's the third
parameter but I think it's ok ok so Y
dot is equal to X that's X 1 times row
minus Z now row is my second beta and Z
is X 3 minus y which is X 2 and then Z
dot is x times y minus beta which is
beta 3 times Z which is X 3 okay so I
just want to double-check that I didn't
mess anything up
X dot is Sigma Y minus X Y dot is X row
minus Z minus y and then Z dot is x
times y minus beta times Z this all
looks good to me I can delete my cheat
sheet here and I have a function now
that when I give it time X and beta it
returns X dot y dot and Z dot in a
vector ok I'm gonna save this as Lorentz
M good I want it to be in the same
folder as this change folder ok
I want that to be Lorentz dot M okay
good so now it's in the same folder as
similar NCM okay so I have my right hand
side I have f of X now if I want to
simulate this what I'm going to do in OD
45 so the first thing I want to do is I
want to define my beta vector what are
the actual numeric values of Sigma Rho
and beta and also what is my initial
condition what's X naught Y naught and Z
dot so let's do that let's say beta
equals and I'm going to use the classic
values that Lawrence used so the chaotic
values 10 28 and then 8/3 so these are
kind of the chaotic values I'm going to
define an X naught so X naught equals 0
1 20 this is my initial condition good
and then I wanted to find what a time
step is what's my delta T and how long
am I going to integrate for so let's say
DT equals 0.001 maybe I want to
integrate a timespan equals dt2 dt2 50
so this is going to be a vector of time
in increments of delta T from 0.001 to
50 so it's gonna be a lot about 50,000
time steps in this time span ok good so
I have my my right hand side in Lorentz
I have my beta parameters my X naught my
time span I think we're ready to go now
all I have to do is define some OD e
options but I don't need to do that
right now so the great thing about OD 45
in MATLAB it's super easy to simulate
back differential equations so the
output is going to be time and the time
history of my state x that's a vector of
states equals ode45 and ode45 takes in
three inputs it takes in a right-hand
side function a time span and an initial
condition so let's give it the
right-hand side function it's going to
be a function of time and space it
always OD 45 always wants a function of
time and space even though our Lorentz
vector field was not time dependent I
still tell it that it can vary this time
variable even if it doesn't change the
right-hand side this is important in
MATLAB and I'm going to wrap this
Lorentz vector field and what did
Lorentz take Lorentz took T comma X
comma beta T comma X comma beta so what
this does in MATLAB is it essentially
takes this function Lorentz which takes
in three inputs T X and beta and it
locks in these values of beta and those
are locked in and it acts like it's just
a function of T and X so it says this is
going to act like it's a function of T
and X by locking in beta and that's what
OD 45 expects it expects just a function
of T comma X here so if I didn't put
this in it wouldn't know what to do with
this this function of 3 3 inputs so it
locks in beta and makes it a function of
2 inputs then I give it my time span and
my X naught initial condition and this
will go this will simulate right off the
bat one thing I like to do is give this
thing some options so that it simulates
a little bit more accurately so you can
control the error tolerances you can say
options equals Oh de set you can set the
relative tolerance to be let's say 1
eeem eyeness 12 and the absolute
tolerance to be 1e minus 12 time one's 1
comma 3 and so what this does is it
basically says that the relative
tolerance is 10 to the minus 12 and the
absolute tolerance of each of the
components is 10 to the minus 12 so
that's going to work nicely and then you
can give these options at the end of OD
45 ok so that's all we've done we have
defined a right-hand side vector field
we put in our parameters our initial
condition DT in the time span we've
given some OD e options so we can dial
down the tolerance so it's very very
accurate and basically what oh D 45 is
going to
do is it's going to adjust its adaptive
time step to make Delta T's smaller and
smaller until it meets these these
relative and absolute tolerances so you
can dial these down or up and then I
call the ode45 command with my Lorentz
right hand side locking in the beta
parameters and I tell it I want to
integrate over this time span starting
at X naught with these options so I can
run this and then what's going to spit
out is a big expectorants a it doesn't
like relative it's not relative tell
it's relative tall with an O L that's a
simple one okay it's running it it's
evaluating and it ran so now I can look
at what the size of X is and it's a
50,000 by 3 vector so the so the first
column is X the second column is Y and
the third column is Z and every row is a
different delta T so now what I can do
is I can say plot 3 the first column of
X by the second column of X by the third
column of X and why don't I make this
why don't I make this white line width
1.5 I'm gonna do a couple things to make
it look nice on this black background so
I'm going to make it a white plot I'm
gonna set my GCA
color to be black I'm gonna set my X
color to be white my Y color to be white
and my Z color to be white and I'm gonna
set my GCF to be color black this is
basically just gonna make it look cool
with a black background and a with a
black background and a white line on top
of its okay let's save this and let's
run so now it's gonna simulate it and
it's gonna plot this thing and hopefully
nice it plotted it on a black background
with a white lorentz
and you can rotate this around if you
want and kind of see it from different
perspectives and different angles so
this is the classic Lorentz butterfly
attractor from different angles really
easy to simulate again mostly we just
defined the right hand side function
here and then we plugged it into ode45
and most everything else was just
plotting okay so very very simple to do
maybe the last thing I'll show you is
just a kind of cool movie I made a long
time ago where this is a little blob of
initial condition uncertainty this red
blob and it's going to be integrated
through this Lorentz system and notice
that it's stretching because this is the
chaotic dynamical system essentially
what happens is any uncertainty in your
initial conditions grows exponentially
in time and eventually mixes on to this
this butterfly attractor because this
looks like butterfly wings so you can
see that these red points are mixing and
mixing and folding on this Lorentz
system let's play this one more time so
these initial conditions are integrating
through and stretching and folding
through these dynamics this is
essentially the definition of chaos is
that there is a sensitive dependence on
the initial conditions so two points
that started very close together can end
up very far apart and after a long
enough it's only kind of a statistical
description of where these red points
will be on this attractor okay so very
easy to simulate in MATLAB you can make
really cool visualizations very simply
and we're going to use this a lot so
this is how we're going to get data for
to test a lot of our systems is by
integrating them in OD 45 and you can
simulate much more complicated systems
okay thank you